[Music]  it's time for et's social study your  quick look at what the stars are posting  online Justin Bieber teased fans on  Instagram with these four pics from  inside the recording studio could there  be new music on the way Jennifer Lopez  Slade in that behind-the-scenes clips  shared on social media while rehearsing  for her very first concert in the  Dominican Republic oh my gosh you're so  excited Reese Witherspoon snapchatted  her epic mother-daughter date night with  her mini-me Ava on a sunset helicopter  ride meanwhile Sofia Vergara made being  sick in bed look flaw less the modern  family star posted this makeup-free  selfie to instagram still looking  gorgeous as ever  [Music]  you